كنا نسمع دائما ان الحياه تبدا في سن
الاربعين وكنا دائما نشعر بان السعاده
تلحقيقيه لم تترك بابنا بعد ولكن ماذا عن
التعاسه
[موسيقى]
اسامه يمر بتجارب عديده وبعدين بعد
الاربعين
دراسه جديده
من العمر يصلون الى اعلى مستويات التعاسه
وليس السعاده فما السبب
[موسيقى]
بعد 40 بالضبط
في الحياه تتطور مع مرور الوقت
[موسيقى]
فبعكس العشرينيات في الاربعينيات من العمر
تساؤلات عده تشغل تفكير المرء حول اهداف
الحياه بعد هذا العمر وحول جدول
الاستمراري فيما هو عليه او تجربه شيء اخر
كذلك تساؤلات حول مكان العيش والامان
المالي وكان الدنيا التي يفترض ان تكون
لطيفه وخفيفه تكشر عن انيابها اكثر من قبل
هذه نصف الحقيقه فالنصف الاخر هو ان
كثيرين يشعرون في منتصف العمر بضروره
استعاده شبابهم والاستمتاع بالحياه رجاله
ونساء ولعلنا نكتشف في النهايه ان لكل
مرحله عمريه
سعادتها الخاصه لصباح العربيه عماد